There's not a mother in this world who
would watch her child cry in the street,
stand and watch her weep.
There's not a mother in this world who
wouldn't give up her
own life for the life of her child.
There's not a mother in this world who
wouldn't be
happy to have a home for her family.
We're all
your homes. We're all
your family.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah
wabarakatuhu.
We welcome all the brothers and sisters
present here today for this evening
session of the 10-day international
Islamic conference.
We begin with the Qirat
by Dr. Othman
bin Muhammad As-Siddiqi,
the head of the Quran societies
in the Ministry of Islamic Affairs,
Government of Saudi Arabia. Please
welcome Dr. Othman As-Siddiqi.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheem.
You read Allah and
What will
in
Sanu
Allah?
Yeah,
are you lazy
and
let
cool
and what
by cool
bill about to lay in love?
In love
to cool and teach a lot and
to
love
me.
Cool.
What
to cool to
and
for second?
In
Allah
woman
Yeah, but I'll that
would you
What would you
for so far
What can
on Allah
in
touch a tiny book
a llama to the hell
and coffee
and
come say
come
No can
and
come say
I think come What do
come
What do call
What do that I tell
What do that I but I'll Allah be
but I'll come What do but I'll
little Reggie
No see
What do
mean
What do see but What do
No see
What do No see
mean
What do see but
What do that I but I'll mean
but I'll mean
in
but I'll
What can be cool
say
What do
mean
What do be cool
What do
What do mean
that I
one
in
again
shame
original
and
Nissan
Bima
about
and
cool
will be my
cool and
cool
the
have
cool
have cool
will
the
cool
will
feel the
the
and will
will
the
in
and
will
Now we have the translation of the Quran
by brother Arshi Qureshi.
Allah wants to accept your repentance.
But those who follow their passions want
to digress into a great deviation.
And Allah wants to lighten for you your
difficulties and mankind was created
weak.
Oh, you who have believed, do not
consume one another's wealth unjustly.
But only in lawful business by mutual
consent.
And do not kill yourself or one another.
Indeed, Allah is to you ever merciful.
And whoever does that in aggression and
injustice,
then we will drive him into a fire, and
that for Allah is always easy.
If you avoid the major sins which you
are forbidden, we will remove from you
your lesser sins and admit you to a
noble entrance into paradise.
And do not wish for that by which Allah
has made some of you exceed others.
For men is a share of what they have
earned, and for women is a share of what
they have earned.
And ask Allah of his bounty.
Indeed, Allah is ever of all things
knowing.
And for all, we have made heirs to what
is left by parents and relatives.
And to those whom your oaths
have bound to you,
give them their share. Indeed, Allah is
ever of all things a witness.
Men are in charge of women by right of
what Allah has given one or the other,
and what they spend for maintenance from
their wealth.
So, righteous women are devoutly
obedient,
guarding in the husband's absence what
Allah would have them guard.
But those wives for whom you fear
arrogance,
first advise them.
Then if they persist,
forsake them in bed. And finally, strike
them.
But if they obey you once more, seek no
means against them. Indeed, Allah is
ever exalted and grand.
Jazakallah, Dr.
Othman as Siddiqui and brother Arshi.
On behalf of the Islamic Research
Foundation,
it's my pleasure
to be your host and coordinator
for today's evening program.
This is the second day of the 10-day
international Islamic conference.
Our speaker for this evening
is renowned as a dynamic international
orator on Islam and comparative
religion.
Yes, Dr. Zakir Naik is popular for his
critical analysis and convincing answers
to challenging questions posed by
audiences after his public talks.
In the last 13 years,
Dr. Zakir has delivered more than 1,300
public talks worldwide in addition to
numerous public talks in India.
He has successfully participated
in several symposia and dialogues with
prominent personalities of other faiths
like Dr. William Campbell of USA
and Sri Sri Ravi Shankar of India.
The Indian Express, one of the leading
newspapers of India,
listed Dr. Zakir Naik amongst the 100
most powerful Indians in 2009.
In the special list of the top 10
spiritual gurus of India, Dr. Zakir Naik
was ranked number three, being the only
Muslim in the list.
Dr. Zakir Naik
appears regularly on many international
satellite TV channels throughout the
world.
Peace TV,
the most-watched Islamic satellite
channel in the world,
having over 100 million viewers, is his
brainchild.
Brothers and sisters, to speak before us
on the topic Women's Rights in Islam
protected or subjugated, Dr. Zakir Naik.
Alhamdulillah.
Was-salatu was-salam ala Rasulillahi wa
ala alihi wa sahbihi ajmain. Amma ba'd.
A'udhu billahi minash shaytanir rajim.
Bismillahir rahmanir rahim.
Innal muslimina wal muslimati wal
mu'minina wal mu'minati wal qanitina wal
qanitati was sadiqina was sadiqati was
sabirina was sabirati wal khashi'ina wal
khashi'ati wal mutasaddiqina wal
mutasaddiqati was sa'imina was sa'imati
wal hafizina furujahum wal hafizati wadh
dhakirina Allaha kathiran wadh dhakirati
a'addallahu lahum maghfiratan ajran
'azima.
Rabbishrah li sadri
wayassir li amri
wahlul 'uqdatan min lisani yafqahu
qawli.
The honorable guest of honor
my respected elders
and my dear brothers and sisters, I
welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings Assalamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
May peace
mercy and blessings
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, of
Almighty God, be on all of you.
The topic
of
this evening's talk is
women's
rights in Islam
protected
or subjugated?
Women's rights
according to the Oxford dictionary are
those rights
that promote
a position
of
social
and legal equality
of women with men.
Women's rights according to Oxford
dictionary means
rights that promote a position of social
and legal equality of women with men.
I'm not too much concerned
about
the conclusions
the modern ideas
and the categorical statements made by
scientists and unexperienced armchair
experts
as how
a life should be led
by a woman.
I'm going to base my conclusions
on experience which has been proven by
facts.
Because
experience and holistic truth
is the sure test
between
the gold of truth and the glitter of
theory.
We have to check
our intellect
because many a time
our mind can go astray.
Indeed
there was a time
when the great minds of that day
they thought
that the world was flat.
If we agree
with how
the Western media portrays
the women's rights in Islam, we have no
option but to agree
that the women's rights in Islam, they
are subjugated and they are not
protected.
The Western talk
of women's liberalization is nothing but
a disguised form
of exploitation of a body, of
deprivation of honor, and degradation of
the soul.
The Western society
claiming to uplift the women have
actually degraded her to a status of
concubines,
mistresses,
and society butterflies,
which are employed as mere tools
in the hands of sex marketers and
pleasure seekers, which are hidden
behind the colorful screen of art and
culture.
Islam
gave women their due rights 1,400 years
ago.
In the Yawmul Jahiliyyah, it was known
as the days of ignorance. Islam gave
women their due rights.
If we go back
into history and analyze,
when we read the history of Babylonian
civilization,
at that time,
if a man committed murder, instead of
him being punished,
his wife was put to death.
When we read the history
of the Greek civilization,
they had a mythological
person by the name of Pandora,
who was a woman,
who was the cause
of evil and misfortune in society.
In the Greek civilization,
the women were used for sex and
pleasure.
When we read the history of Roman
civilization,
when the Roman civilization reached its
peak,
a man was permitted to even kill his
wife.
Women
were used for sex and pleasure. Nudity
and promiscuity was common.
When we read the history
of the Egyptian civilization,
they considered
the woman as a sign of the devil.
When we read the Arab civilization
before the Quran was revealed, very
often when a female child was born, she
was buried alive.
Alhamdulillah.
Praise be to Allah.
After the revelation of the Quran,
and after the teaching of the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him, the last
and final messenger of the creator Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala,
the woman got the due rights.
It uplifted
the status of woman.
Imagine in the days of ignorance, it was
known as Yawm al-Jahiliyyah. The Arabs
were the most ignorant people of that
time.
And after the revelation of the Quran,
the woman, they got the due rights.
Before we discuss
the women's rights in Islam,
I would like
to point a few things.
Muslims today,
approximately, they constitute 20 to 25%
of the world population. 1/5 to 1/4 of
the world population today are Muslims.
Some Muslim societies,
they're close to Islam,
while the others, they are far away from
Islam.
If anyone
wants to judge
the women's rights in Islam,
he should not judge
according to what Muslims do, or what
the Muslim society does.
The women's rights in Islam should be
based on the authentic sources of Islam.
The authentic sources of Islam are the
glorious Quran,
the last and final revelation
of Almighty God, and the authentic
Hadith of the last and final messenger,
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him. So,
women's rights in Islam should only be
judged and based on the authentic
sources of Islam, the glorious Quran,
and the authentic sayings of the beloved
Prophet Muhammad S.A.W.
The Quranic verses
will never contradict among themselves.
Neither would the Sahih Hadith.
The Quran and the Sahih Hadith then
confirmity. They will never contradict
themselves.
Yet we find
that there are Muslim scholars,
they have difference of opinion in many
aspects of the women.
The main reason is
that these scholars, they quote one
particular verse of the Quran and
neglect all the other verses of the
Quran. The Quran should be read as a
whole.
And if we read the Quran as a whole,
most of these differences will be
solved.
It's the duty of every true Muslim,
whether man or woman,
to seek the pleasure of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala, Almighty God.
The main aim should not be to get famous
or to satisfy one's own ego. The main
aim of every Muslim, whether man or
woman, is to seek the pleasure of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Men and women in Islam, they are equal.
But equality does not mean identicality.
They're equal, but they are not
identical.
Depending upon the biological makeup
of the man and woman.
There are differences.
Depending upon the biological makeup of
the man and woman. Depending upon the
physiological makeup.
Depending upon the psychological makeup.
Depending upon the physical makeup.
Almighty God Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
has given different roles
for men and women.
Many a time
they're exactly the same and they're
identical. And sometimes they differ
depending upon
the biological background, the
physiological background, the
psychological background, the physical
background.
He's our creator. He knows
what is best for us.
I have divided my talk
the women's rights in Islam into six
broad headings.
The spiritual rights of the women in
Islam, the economic rights of the women
in Islam,
the social rights of the women in Islam,
the educational rights of the women in
Islam, the legal rights
of the women in Islam, and the political
rights
of the women in Islam.
I've divided my talk into six
broad headings.
First we'll discuss
the spiritual rights of the women in
Islam.
There is a very common misconception
especially amongst the Westerners
that in Islam
paradise is only meant for the men.
Only for the males.
This misconception
can be easily clarified by quoting just
one verse of the Quran.
Of Surah Nisa.
Chapter number four, verse number 124,
where Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says
Wa mai ya'mal min as-salihati min
dhakarin
that if any of you
do deeds of righteousness,
be it a male or a female,
and has faith,
he will surely enter Jannah.
He will surely go to heaven, and
not the least injustice shall be done to
them.
The same message repeated
in Surah Nahl,
chapter number 16,
verse number 97,
where Allah says, that if any of you
do good deeds,
be it a male or a female,
and is a believer,
we will surely reward him for what he
has done,
and we will make him lead a good life.
These verses are explicit and clear
that going to paradise
depends upon a person's faith and his
righteous deeds.
Iman and Amal e Salihat.
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Nisa,
chapter number four, verse number one,
wa khalaqa minha zawjaha.
O humankind, reverence your guardian
Lord, who has created you from a single
person,
and has created
his mate
of like nature.
That means
the mate
of the man,
that is the female,
has been created of the same spiritual
nature as that of the man.
Further words mentioned
in Surah Shura,
chapter number 42, verse number 11,
Fatir us-Samawati wal-Ard.
Ja'ala
It is he who has created the heaven and
the earth and created like nature has
made.
That means the spiritual nature of man
and woman is the same.
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Sajdah
chapter number 32, verse number nine.
Summa sawwahu
wa nafakha fihi min ruhihi
that we have made them in due proportion
and have blown into them our spirit.
The same message repeated in Surah
Al-Hijr, chapter number 15, verse number
29, that Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala has
created the human beings in due
proportion and has put into them his
spirit.
And then they fall down in obedience.
What does Allah mean when he says that
we have blown the spirit into the human
beings? It does not mean
something like a god incarnate
or something like a pantheistic form. It
means that Almighty God has given his
knowledge into every human being.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala has given the
knowledge of the creator in all the
human beings, the males as well as the
females.
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Isra
chapter number 17 verse number 70.
Wa laqad karramna bani Adam. We have
honored the children of Adam.
Almighty God says in the Quran that all
the children of Adam
all the children of Adam, irrespective
whether they're male or female, they
have been honored. Irrespective whether
they're black or white, yellow or brown,
rich or poor, Almighty God has honored
all the children of Adam.
Irrespective whether they're staying in
America, in UK, in Canada, in India, in
Saudi Arabia, almighty God has honored
all the children of Adam.
There are certain non-Islamic religions
who put the blame only on Eve. May Allah
be pleased with her.
For tempting Adam
to eat the forbidden fruit, because of
which humankind is born in sin.
And when you read the Bible,
Genesis chapter number three, it says
that Eve, may Allah be pleased with her,
was responsible for tempting Adam to eat
the forbidden fruit, because of which
humankind is born in sin.
There is not a single verse in the Quran
which puts the blame only on Eve. May
Allah be pleased with her.
The blame is put equally on both of
them, on Adam as well as on Eve. May
peace be upon them.
And if you read the Quran,
it's mentioned in Surah Al-A'raf,
chapter number seven, verse number 19 to
27,
Adam and Eve, peace be upon them, they
are addressed a dozen of times.
It's mentioned there
that both of them, they made a mistake.
Both of them repented, and both were
forgiven. The blame is put equally on
both of them. There is not a single
verse of the Quran which puts the blame
on Eve alone exclusively. But
there is a verse in the Quran in Surah
Taha, chapter number 20, verse number
121, which says that Adam, peace be upon
him, he disobeyed God.
But there's no verse exclusively
saying
that Eve was responsible, peace be upon
her.
But overall, if you read the Quran, as I
said, you cannot pick up one verse. If
you read the Quran overall, we have to
agree that both of them, they made a
mistake, both of them repented, and both
were forgiven.
Further, when you read the Bible,
in the book of Genesis chapter number
three verse number 16 it says
Almighty God says
he says to the woman that I will
multiply your conception
and you will give birth in pain and
sorrow.
And your desire shall be your husband
and he will rule over you.
So according to the Bible pregnancy is a
curse of Almighty God. It's a
punishment.
God says I will multiply you in
conception.
And you will bear children in pain and
sorrow.
As though it's a punishment of Almighty
God on the woman. Pregnancy is a curse,
it's a punishment.
And it says that your desire shall be
that of your husband and he will rule
you.
In fact if you read the Quran
there's a great contrast.
The Quran says exactly the opposite. The
Quran
uplifts the woman because of pregnancy.
The Quran says in Surah Nisa chapter
number four verse number one
it says respect the womb that bore you.
Quran says in Surah Luqman chapter
number 31 verse number 14 we have
enjoined on the human beings
to be kind to the parents.
In travail upon travail did the mother
bore you and in pain did she give you
birth.
The Quran says respect your parents
especially your mother because she bore
you in pain.
In trouble upon trouble did she bore you
and in pain she give you birth.
Same message repeated in Surah Ahqaf
chapter number 46 verse number 15.
Wa wassaynal insana
bi walidayhi ihsana. We have enjoined on
the human beings to be good to the
parents.
In pain did she bore you and in pain did
she give you birth.
That means
because of
the pains that the mother bears
and the pain she takes while giving you
birth, the Quran says you have to
respect her.
It uplifts the woman. Pregnancy uplifts
the woman, does not degrade her.
And if you analyze the Quran,
the Quran gives the criteria of Almighty
God to judge a human being in Surah
Hujurat, chapter number 49, verse number
13, where it says,
Oh, humankind,
we have created you from a single pair
of male and female, and have divided you
into nations and tribes, so that you
shall recognize each other, not that you
shall despise each other. And the most
honored in the sight of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala is the person who has taqwa.
The only criteria for Almighty God to
differentiate one human being above
other, it is not sex, it's not caste,
it's not color, it's not wealth, it's
not age, but it is taqwa. It is God
consciousness. It is piety. It's
righteousness.
The only criteria for Almighty God to
differentiate one human being above the
other,
it is God consciousness. It is piety. It
is righteousness. It is never sex.
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Al
Imran, chapter number three, verse
number 195,
"Never will I suffer the loss of any of
you, be it male or female. You are
partners unto one another."
Almighty God says, "Never will I let any
of your work go waste, irrespective
whether you are a male or a female. You
are partners unto one another."
The spiritual aspects
of the men and women
has been described in a nutshell
in Surah Ahzab
chapter number 33, verse number 35, the
ayah that I quoted in the beginning of
my talk
where Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says
Innal Muslimeena wal Muslimati
for Muslim men and women wal Mu'mineena
wal Mu'minati
for believing men and women
wal Qaniteena wal Qanitati for devout
men and women
was Sadiqina was Sadiqati
for true men and women
was Sabireena was Sabirati for men and
women who are patient and constant
wal Khashi'eena wal Khashi'ati for men
and women, those who humble themselves
wal Mutasaddiqeena wal Mutasaddiqati
for men and women who give in charity
was Sa'imeena was Sa'imati
for men and women who fast
wal Hafizeena furujahum wal Hafizati
for men and women
who guard their chastity and modesty
waz Zakireenallaha katheeraw waz
Zakirati for men and women who engage
much in Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala's praise
a'addallahu lahum maghfiratan wa ajran
'azeema
for them
Allah has prepared forgiveness and ample
of reward
Allah says
that
for Muslim men and women
for believing men and women
for devout men and women
for true men and women
for men and women who are patient as
well as constant
for men and women who humble themselves
for men and women who give in charity
for men
and women who guard their chastity and
modesty
for men and women who engage
in Allah's praise.
For them
Allah has prepared forgiveness and ample
of reward.
By reading this verse we come to know
that the spiritual duties of men and
women in Islam are the same.
Both have to submit their will to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Both have to
believe.
Both have to be devout. Both have to be
true.
Both have to do sabr, patience and
constancy.
Both have to pray.
Both have to give charity.
Both have to fast.
Both
have to praise Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
By these verses of the Quran we come to
know that spiritually
men and women are equal.
Just because
the Quran says that spiritually men and
women are equal, what would you decide?
Are
the women's rights in Islam
protected or are they subjugated?
Let's discuss
the economic rights
of the women in Islam.
Islam
gave a woman the economic rights 1,400
years ago.
1,300 years before the Western world.
When the Quran was revealed
at the advent of the Prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, any adult
woman
whether married or unmarried, she was
allowed to own or disown the property
without the permission of anyone else.
If you read history
the first time the Westerners
gave right
for a married woman to own or disown the
property without the permission of the
husband was in 1870s
under the special married woman property
act.
And this special
women's marriage property act was
further revised in 1882 and 1897.
Imagine.
Islam gave rights to the woman to own or
disown 1300 years before the Western
world.
In Islam
a woman is financially more than
secured.
Before she's married
it is the duty of her father and her
brother.
And after she's married, it's the duty
of her husband and her son to look after
her financial aspects, lodging,
boarding, clothing, and all of the
financial aspects. She need not work for
a living. Financially, a woman is
secured.
It is
the duty of the man in the house to earn
the living. The financial burden is put
on the shoulders of the men in Islam.
But if both the ends don't meet
and the woman wants to work, she can
work as long as it is within the purview
of the Islamic Sharia.
She maintains the hijab.
And she follows the Quran and say hadith
because there's no verse in the Quran
which prohibits a woman to work as long
as it is not against the Quran and the
say hadith.
There are many professions which are
prohibited for the woman.
Those professions
which exhibit the body.
For example, modeling
acting, dancing, all these professions,
they are haram for the woman. It's
prohibited.
Furthermore, there are many professions
which are prohibited for the women as
well as the men.
For example
working in alcoholic bars
working in gambling den
doing dishonest business
cheating, bribing, all these are
prohibited for both men and women.
There are many professions
which are noble
and
we want the women to do.
There are some professions which if the
woman want the both the ends to meet,
they can do. For example, they can do
cooking at home,
pottery, weaving, knitting.
They can work in places which have got
segregation of sexes where the modesty
is protected, where the hijab is
maintained.
They can take up noble professions such
as teaching.
They can become nurses and doctors.
If I want my wife,
my mother, my daughter to maintain a
hijab, but natural, we should make our
women folk some of them as doctors.
But if you analyze in Islam,
the woman is financially secured. She
need not work for a living.
It's the duty of the man to look after
the financial burden.
Before she's married, as I mentioned,
it's the duty of the father and the
brother. And after she's married, it's
the duty of the husband and the son to
look after her lodging, boarding,
clothing, and all financial aspects. She
need not work.
But if she works and if that work is
within the purview of the Islamic
Sharia,
then whatever she earns,
she need not spend on the family.
She can keep it for herself.
That's her right.
But if she wants to take part
and help in the financial aspects, she
can. But no one can force her.
In Islam,
during marriage,
the woman is on the receiving end.
The Quran says in Surah Nisa, chapter
number four, verse number four,
Wa'atun Nisa'a
satu raatinna nehla.
That give to the woman in marriage a
dowry as a gift.
In Islam, meher
that is a marital gift is compulsory for
a marriage to solemnize.
Without meher, a marriage cannot
solemnize in Islam.
In Indian culture
where we live, it is the opposite.
It is
the woman
who gives dowry to the would-be husband.
In Islam
it's opposite.
It is the man who gives to the would-be
wife meher, a marital gift.
A dowry.
But unfortunately
in the Muslim society, many of us
have made it as a joke.
You know, in India, we keep meher as 786
rupees.
You can't even buy a pair of shoes with
786 rupees.
And for name's sake, they keep 2,000
rupees or 19 miskal.
You know, saying that the prophet kept
19 miskal as meher.
If you have the same wealth as the
prophet and Hazrat Ali, may Allah be
pleased with him. And if you give 19
miskal, 19 miskal gold, you may be
having 10 times, 100 times more wealth
than what the prophet had and Hazrat
Ali, may Allah be pleased with him. And
you want to give 19, you have to give
190, 1,900 miskal if you want to follow
the prophet.
They spend on the
weddings lavishly.
They may keep the nikah in the mosque
for name's sake, but a walima on a big
ground.
Spending lakhs of rupees
millions of rupees
and they want to keep a meher as 786.
They want to make a mockery of Islam.
The Indian culture, unfortunately, some
of the Muslims, they're are being
influenced by the Indian culture.
You know in Indian culture,
it is the woman that gives the dowry to
the would-be husband.
And you know, depending upon the market,
if you want to marry a graduate,
you may have to give 5 lakh rupees, half
a million rupees. If you want to marry
an engineer, you have to give 10 lakh
rupees, 1 million rupees. If you have to
marry a doctor,
you may have to give 50 lakh rupees, 5
million rupees. As though herds and
cattle are being sold in the
marketplaces.
In Islam,
to demand
dowry
from the would-be wife is haram. It is
prohibited. Demanding directly or
indirectly, both prohibited. You can't
tell the parents of the would-be bride
that my son, he likes to travel in a
Mercedes car.
Giving an indication, I want a Mercedes
car for dowry. You know, my son, he
likes to live in a three-bedroom
apartment. Giving an indication that you
want a three-bedroom apartment for
dowry.
Demanding dowry directly or indirectly
is prohibited in Islam. If willingly, if
the parents of the girl, the bride, want
to give some gift to the daughter,
there's no problem. But you cannot force
or cannot ask or request directly or
indirectly, it is prohibited in Islam.
So if you analyze in Islam,
the woman, they are on the receiving end
during marriage.
And furthermore, irrespective,
the woman may be very rich.
The wife may be very rich or she may be
poor.
Irrespective whether the husband is rich
or poor, it is yet the duty of the
husband
to look after the food, clothing,
lodging, and all financial aspects of
the wife.
He cannot say, "Okay, my wife is rich,
I'm poor."
Yet it is his duty.
Furthermore, just in case
if divorce takes place
or if a woman gets widowed
she gets maintenance for the iddah
period, for the waiting period.
And if she's pregnant, it extends
till she gives delivery of the child.
Till she gives birth of the child. And
if the child is born, she even gets
financial support
till the child grows up.
Furthermore, in Islam
a woman even inherits.
In many religions
the woman is not allowed to inherit. She
does not have any share
in the property left behind by her
family members.
But in Islam
the woman inherits.
There are on many occasions
where non-Muslims
they object and they say, "Fine, in
Islam women do inherit, but why do they
inherit half?"
Trying to say that Islam
subjugates the woman.
But if you analyze the logic behind it
you'll understand
the wisdom of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
of our creator, almighty God.
As I mentioned a few minutes earlier.
In Islam
it is the man
who bears the financial burden.
Before woman is married
it is the father and the brother. After
she's married, it is the husband and the
son who looks after her lodging,
boarding, clothing, and all financial
aspects.
If you read the Quran
the inheritance is given in several
places. In Surah Baqarah, chapter number
two, verse number 180. In Surah Baqarah,
chapter number two, verse number 240. In
Surah Nisa, chapter number four, verse
number 79. In Surah Nisa, chapter number
four, verse number 19. In Surah Nisa,
chapter number four, verse number 33, in
Surah Ma'ida, chapter number five, verse
number 106 to 108, in several places.
But the most specific share
division is given in Surah Nisa, chapter
number four, verse number 11 and 12.
Where it says
that Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala has
ordained
that in what you leave your wealth for
your children,
the sons
get double the share of the daughters.
If only daughters,
two or more, they share into third. If
only one, she gets half.
The verse continues, in what you leave
for your parents, each get 1/6 if you
have children.
The mother gets 1/3
if there are no children, and the verse
continues.
In what your wives leave for you,
you get half if there are no children.
You get 1/4 if there are children. What
you leave for your wives,
they get 1/4 if there are no children,
they get 1/8
if you have children.
Don't confuse yourself. Go back home,
open the Quran, Surah Nisa, chapter
four, verse number 11 and 12. Easy.
I do agree that most of the times the
woman inherit half
the amount what the men inherit. But
there are occasions when they inherit
equal. For example, 1/6 both for the
parents, for mother and father, if they
have children. But if they don't have
children,
mother gets 1/3.
That means double than that of the
father.
But I do agree with you, as a whole,
most of the times
the woman inherit half.
Son gets double than that
of the daughter.
Husband gets double than that of the
wife, most of the time.
What is the logic behind it?
The logic is, as I mentioned, since man
is the person who takes the financial
burden,
and suppose
there's a person who dies
and
after giving the shares of the other
people
if
$150,000
or 150,000 rupees is balanced
for the children after giving the shares
of the
other relatives. If $150,000
150,000 rupees is balanced and that man
has got one daughter and one son. The
son will get $100,000 100,000 rupees and
the daughter will get $50,000 or 50,000
rupees. People will say injustice.
Why did the daughter get half?
But the logic behind it is
the man
has the financial burden. I'm asking a
question, would you want to inherit
$100,000 100,000 rupees and spend 80 or
90% of that whatever you inherited on
the family if you are a man or would you
prefer inheriting $50,000 or 50,000
rupees and not spending a single penny
or single paisa on the family?
If you are a man and if you inherit
$100,000 100,000 rupees
maybe 80 or 90% goes on the family. What
is left with you?
10,000 20,000 rupees or dollars.
If you are a woman,
you get $50,000 or 50,000 rupees. 100%
you keep for yourself. So would you
prefer inheriting 100,000
and keeping only 10,000 20,000 with you
or would you prefer inheriting 50,000
and keeping everything with you?
If
Allah
would have given equal amount to both,
then I would have to give a talk on
men's rights in Islam.
When Allah has given the rights, he's
given equal. He says put the financial
burden on the men, he sees to it that
the men get double. Otherwise, it will
be injustice.
And the Quran says in Surah Nisa chapter
number 4 verse number 40, Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala is never unjust in the least
degree.
So, if you know the hikmah behind it,
you'll realize that the guidance is
given by our creator is the best.
Just because
the woman in Islam
are financially more secured than the
men,
what would you say? The women in Islam
are they protected
or are they subjugated?
Let's discuss.